well have joined Again by Jordan
Peterson Jordan it's been that one year
can you believe that since you came and
sat in my studio and we had what was an
extraordinary uh interview got very
emotional uh one part of it uh a can you
believe it's a year and what kind of
reaction did you have to that interview
because some of the clips went so big
and everyone was having a view about it
what was your reaction
well I enjoyed talking to you and I was
I'm never that happy really when I
become emotional about something that's
being discussed and sometimes for me
that's a consequence of not exactly
Optimal Health you know it makes me a
little bit more emotionally fragile than
I'd like to be but by the same token I I
wasn't unhappy with it I do still hold
to my belief that I am addressing
um a loss A demoralization among young
people and maybe particularly young men
and that I don't feel that there's
anything inappropriate about that and
you know I have toured all over the
world and I've seen the extent of
demoralization among young people and it
is very affecting if you
if you have a clue as far as I'm
concerned and so we touched on that and
um I mean other than that I was very
happy I was very happy overall with the
interview and with the re and with the
manner in which people received it I was
too I had an extraordinary reaction just
in the streets you know of London and
New York people coming up to me wanting
to talk about it wanting to know what I
thought of you and it made me realize
just how wide your influence is and how
important you are to so many people
especially actually young men uh how do
you how do you feel about that influence
and power that you have through that
influence over so many young minds
well I hope it's not power you know
because power is not a good thing you
have to be a fool to want Power
if it's influenced that's a good thing
if it's an Invitational influence that's
a better thing if it is um the sort of
influence that encourages people to
stand up on their own and to help them
believe that they can do that and that
they should do it and that the world is
a lesser place if they don't then that's
a good thing and and I do think that
that's what's happening that's the
stories I received from people and I
would say it's daunting because
to understand that the message that
you're conveying has played an important
part in people's lives is an immense
responsibility and you have to handle
that with all due caution you know I do
everything I can in my lectures and when
I meet people when I talk to people to
be pleased as I can possibly be that
they're positively affected by
what I've been doing and I would also
say you know I I'd like to distinguish
it too I don't like to think in some
ways that it's what I've been doing you
know I'm an educated clinical
psychologist and the reason that the
words that I'm using and the stories I'm
telling are having an effect is because
they're deeply grounded in a solid
scientific tradition and also in a solid
philosophical psychological and
Theological tradition and insofar as the
message that I'm conveying has potency
it's because of its fundamental
grounding in those underlying Traditions
rather than something that is directly a
consequence of me or should be
attributed to me and I know the
difference between those two things you
know and so I'm careful to try to make
sure that I don't confuse the messenger
with the message let's say right I
interviewed Stephen Pinker recently and
he uh he'd always said for years that
we've never had it so good as a planet
that statistically whether it was
poverty or health or age or whatever it
may be they'll almost on almost every
recordable metric this is the best time
to ever be alive and I asked him whether
posts the pandemic the war in Ukraine
the cost of living crisis around the
world did he still feel that that held
true and he said yes that actually
despite that this is the best time
actually in in many ways to ever be
alive when I read your Twitter feed
which I find fascinating exciting uh
challenging combative but often quite
Furious I get a sense of somebody quite
angry with the state of the world is
that a fair reflection of your state of
mind about the world if so why
well we've we've we've swapped adventure
for security and painker rightly points
to the fact that on the grounds of
material security as well satiety
satisfaction let's say we're doing
better than we ever have but people
aren't built for infantile satiation
they're built for truthful Adventure as
far as I'm concerned and so to the
degree that we've purchased
security and and safety at the cost of
existential Adventure that is not an
advance now I think being optimistic
like Pinker that we could have an
adventure we could have our cake and eat
it too let's put it that way we could we
could make the world an abundant place
and and there would still be room for an
adventure for everyone but I think the
the existential or the or the
enlightenment types like Pinker they
make a mistake when they presume that
mere material well-being is sufficient
to to to provide people with the meaning
that's that's a necessary that's
necessary to offset the fundamental
existential uncertainty of their lives
you know we're mortal creatures and
we're we're prone to Decay and to the
loss of everything that we have even if
we're rich and you need a meaning that
offsets that and I don't think the
enlightenment types have done a good job
of addressing that at all they don't
really understand
or they refuse to understand the depth
of that spiritual longing am I angry
um no I wouldn't say precisely so um I
I'm upset at many things that I see I
think the Net Zero move is is is a
travesty in in five different dimensions
I'm absolutely appalled that the
globalist utopian elitists would
sacrifice the poor to save the planet
especially when there's no evidence
whatsoever that they're actually
effectively saving the planet and we
could take Germany as a case in point
there and I would say the UK to some
degree but I'm I'm fundamentally
optimistic I think that people I think
that human beings
can solve any problem that's set
in front of them this is also another
place where I think the apocalyptic
utopians have got something seriously
wrong like they basically take a
zero-sum approach to
to economic analysis of the world we
have finite resources there's only room
for a certain number of people and so of
course that begs the question of what in
the world you're going to do with all
those excess people and we have to you
know we have to move towards degrowth or
there's going to be an apocalypse and I
think everything about that set of
presuppositions is wrong we don't live
in a zero-sum universe the apocalyptic
outcome that everyone's predicting isn't
necessary and the more fundamental truth
of the matter is is that people if
people adopt
subsidiary responsibility and we could
get into what that means and we organize
our social hierarchies effectively and
generously we could make the Desert
Bloom we can make much out of virtually
nothing and and that's and human beings
have that capacity because we can
transform cognitively and there's no
reason to assume at all that we couldn't
have more than enough for everyone now
that would mean those who want more for
themselves than for other people would
have to let go of that essentially power
mad
desire and be willing to share and be
willing to raise the poor out of poverty
and of course doing so decreases the gap
between rich and poor and that's very
annoying if you're narcissistic and Rich
you spoke last night actually at the
Buckley Institute in New York and you
said something really interesting to me
how do you have the adventure of your
life you asked the people there could be
many students and your answer was tell
the truth and then it's so bloody
interesting and engaging and exciting
that it justifies the misery of your
existence what can I tell you there are
great books read them ignore your
professors I mean I did love that
because actually there is a real power
isn't there to the truth particularly in
this era I think where there's so much
untruth and disinformation flying around
actually being true to yourself
is probably the most powerful thing you
can you can be I think
well you you can think about that in two
ways I mean the first way is
who are you if you lie
now I would say well you're false if you
lie that seems self-evident
if you're false when you lie then who
are you you're not you and so then
whatever happens to you when you lie
that isn't happening to you and the
theological view of that is that
whatever happens to you when you lie is
happening to the spirit of the LIE right
and and the spirit of the LIE
classically speaking is a demonic spirit
and so whatever success you accrue as a
consequence of lying isn't your success
it accrues to the it Crews to the glory
of the spirit who lies and that's a very
bad idea but then as well
The Adventurous element of the truth is
associated with the following idea
I mean I could come on this interview
let's say and I could have been thinking
this morning well what in the world do I
want to accomplish if I get to talk to
Pierce Morgan I'm going to talk to
several million people how can I grow my
brand how can I use this opportunity to
ensure that people feel better about me
or admire me more or something
hypothetically self-serving okay but
it's not self-serving exactly it's it
would serve a very narrow part of myself
it would assert it would serve the
narcissistic self-aggrandizing whim
oriented hedonistic element of myself
and maybe I would confuse that with
myself but that would be foolish
and then maybe I would get what I aimed
at and I'd have a impressive
conversation with Pierce Morgan and that
would re down temporary to my glory and
I would walk away satisfied but the
problem with that is it's a stupid goal
and if I attained it that would just
make me successful at being a being
foolish and narcissistic and the
consequence of doing that repeatedly
would be that I would become more and
more foolish and narcissistic and
there's no success in that even if I got
rich doing that I'd be rich and pathetic
and that's not helpful and alternatively
I could come on here and I could just
try to say what I believe to be the case
and then that would be me
and it would be the truth and then I
would be aligned with reality which
seems like a good idea you know because
if it's you against reality like good
luck to you but there's more to it
Pierce because
see if I want to come on to your program
saying just say what I think I have to
throw caution to the wind I can't be
calculating the outcome I can't be like
what would you say referring to an
opinion poll and telling people what
they want to hear I just have to lay it
on the line and to do that I have to let
go of the outcome but the cool thing
here's the cool thing if you let go of
the outcome
you don't know what's going to happen
and then that's so interesting really
that it's almost unbearable and that is
definitely something so interesting that
it's almost unbearable that's an
adventure and then you get to have an
adventure and then you think wow well
this is so interesting maybe it's worth
sticking around for and trudging through
the misery just to see how it ends and I
do believe that you I do believe you
capture that in a relationship with the
truth yes I truly believe that I don't
agree mystically even I agree and what's
fascinating actually is that whenever
I've interviewed you or done your
podcast and I'm feeling it again now I
agree with so much of what you say but
that's not really the point I believe
that you come from a place of
authenticity and I think there are other
people like that Joe Rogan is another
one that I watch him I don't always
agree with him but I always feel he's
authentic in a different way and to a
lesser degree but I think the point's
the same someone like Andrew Tate I
could see why he resonates so much with
young men in particular because much of
what he says they feel feels a void in
their lies where they feel oppressed as
a group of people and he gives them a
sense of empowerment so I get I get that
and it's interesting that I cite the
three of you because Gavin Newsom who's
the governor of California and many
think may end up being the Democrat
nominee for the presidency next year he
said this he said I have a very serious
conversation with my eldest daughter
about the chat bots on Snapchat I really
worry about the misinformation
disinformation about what's happening
with our country but I really worry
about these micro Cults that my kids are
in I say micro Cults because I don't
know if there's a better way to describe
it my son is asking me about Andrew Tate
Jordan Peterson and then immediately
he's talking about Joe Rogan and I'm
like here it is the pathway and when I
read that I sort of laughed because I
thought what what pathway do you think
that is well that card statement was
unconsciously comical in four dimensions
which is pretty remarkable achievement
as far as I'm concerned I mean first of
all anybody who talks about
misinformation and disinformation that
the misinformation and disinformation
that other people are spreading is they
immediately invalidate themselves as a
serious observer in my viewpoint because
they're they're basically arbitrary
sensors I mean it's not as if we have
some stellar and completely omniscient
manner of distinguishing truth from
falsehood which is why we have free
speech so we can house things out and if
people are foolish enough to believe
that there's some straightforward way of
identifying the purveyors of myths and
disinformation which is what the U.N
insists upon now then they are in fact
identifying themselves as the prime
purveyors of such falsehood I would say
then the micro called comment that's
just ridiculously funny because if you
are Daft enough to think that Joe Rogan
is a micro cult you live in 1995. Joe
Rogan is the most powerful journalist
who's ever lived by a by an order of
magnitude and if you don't know that
you're just not in the you're not in the
modern world and so and young people are
in the modern world and they know that
Joe Rogan isn't a micro cult and Gavin
Newsom might not know that but that just
means that he's he's anachronistic
enough to be deluded so that's pretty
damn funny and then the next part that's
funny is that maybe if Newsom had a clue
he'd be curious about why his own
children are interested in these
microcults and and exactly what what it
is about let's say Tate and Rogan and I
that are grouped together even though
it's a strange grouping I mean I'm not
particularly happy to be grouped with
Andrew Tate because I think that he
there's some elements about what he does
that are quite reprehensible but that we
could certainly talk about that
um and so
so you know there should be some
Curiosity on Newsome's front trying to
figure out why it is that this degree of
popularity exists and then the pathway
comment is also extremely comical I
tweeted out after that it's like well
yeah Gavin you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
we're going to turn your girls into
women and your boys into man and I know
that's a dreadful proposition but well
you know it's just so Preposterous I
don't know well I don't know who he
thinks he is in the most fundamental
sense and that's really something
crucial since he's likely going to run
for president right and I don't know
what world he thinks he lives in but he
certainly has virtually zero curiosity
you know and I should point out as well
Pierce I have invited many many many
many many Democrats onto my podcast and
one has agreed and that's going to be
broadcast soon but for years I've worked
and I have very many contacts with
Democrats by the way they're all
terrified to come on my podcast they
won't talk to me and so if it is a micro
cult at least half the reason for that
is that the damn
uh useful idiots on the Progressive side
let's say are too terrified of the woke
mob to come out and actually have a
conversation well this leads me this
leads me very absolutely comical right
well it leads that last sentence leads
me very neatly to your bet Noir the
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
the man who told us that the word
mankind should be replaced by people
kind uh the man who virtue signals for
the world and yet was caught repeatedly
having blacked his face and the man who
only a few days ago uh joined in a
Novation in the Canadian Parliament for
an actual Nazi
um this is a guy who to me Embraces all
that is bad about the woke virtue
signaling world
because he's riddled with hypocrisy I
mean when you saw the the Nazi thing
last week what was your reaction
oh living in living in Justin Trudeau's
Canada it's a never it's a never-ending
hallucinogenic surreal dream
it Justin Trudeau's mode of governance
is to
top each scandal with a bigger Scandal
and he's really good at that so it's
like literally for the last
virtually for the entire course of his
governance there's just been one scandal
after another and what happens is the
newest one obliterates the previous ones
in the imaginations of Canadians and I
mean in the last two weeks alone he
managed to go to the G20 to alienate the
prime minister of India to start a trade
war with India to make the Indian
government so irritated they decided not
to give visas to Canadians anymore and
he did that to maintain his idiot
Coalition with the narcissist in Canada
jagmeet saying the leader the Socialist
who's who is just as bad as Trudeau and
lacks his intelligence which is a really
pretty dismal uh insult let me tell you
and and then he called a whole sequence
of protesters across Canada who are
parents LED mostly by Muslims who were
quite traditionalists he called them
misogynists and bigots just like he did
the trucker Convoy and then he invited
he he set up the circumstance so that
while zelenski was there there was a
literal not Nazi SS Nazi yet so like the
best kind of Nazi let's say addressing
the Canadian house of Parliament and
then he when he apologized because he
eventually did he really didn't take any
responsibility and offered his own
speaker as a sacrificial lab it's like
and that was just last week and you
might say well what's wrong with
Canadians and I can tell you what's
wrong with Canadians is that Canadians
have a very difficult choice to make
they can either wake up and realize that
under the jurisdiction of this
Preposterous narcissist we've
compromised virtually every institution
of Integrity in Canada which is a really
bitter period of pill to swallow or we
can assume that everyone who's pointing
that out is some sort of conspiracy
theorist and it's way easier for
Canadians to follow to swallow the
latter story than to actually contend
with the true ramifications of the
former story now unfortunately the
former story is true so that's okay
what's his jewelry right now you've been
ordered I don't even know if that's the
right word to use to take social media
training by a Canadian court because you
posted tweets criticizing the
transgender and body positivity
movements my first question is do you
intend to do this
oh well I've got all sorts of evil plans
on that front I mean at the moment we've
appealed the decision of the court in
Canada to allow the college to proceed
with their re-education of me now the
re-education
um what are the criteria of the
re-education program is that I'm
required to sit down with a social media
expert whatever the hell that is because
that's not a genuine that's not a
genuine occupation I don't even know how
you define it and I'm supposed to also
as a clinician be very careful about how
I allow myself to be educated let's say
I'm supposed to educate myself according
to the the tenets of scientific
investigation for example or Rec require
recognize clinical practice and social
media expert doesn't fit into those
categories anyways I'm supposed to sit
down with a social media expert and then
I'm supposed to modify my attitude
however I'm supposed to do that until
they're satisfied the that I've changed
and you know that's not that likely as
far as I can tell because I haven't
changed since I was three years old
really in some core elements and and I
do that at my own expense for an
unlimited amount of time until they've
decided in their wisdom that I've
learned whatever the hell said of
lessons I'm supposed to learn and so
we've appealed that decision we we're
we're planning if necessary to take it
to the Supreme Court I don't know if
they'll happen and
um but if it doesn't and I then the next
thing they have to do to take me in
front of a disciplinary hearing right to
sort me out before they actually throw
me in front of the re-education
specialist but it's also up until now
it's also Preposterous isn't it I mean
the idea that in a modern democratic
society which Canada purports to be the
idea they take one of its great thinkers
you know clinical psychologists like
you're someone who literally is one of
the smarter thinkers and brains in the
country and think that they can get a
social media expert whatever that is to
re-educate you about views that you
honestly hold about some of the insanity
of the gender debate or the insanity of
the body positivity debate and we had a
case here where Cosmopolitan magazine
put a model on the front cover 305
pounds five foot tall that is morbid
obesity and in the interview that
accompanied it not a single word
suggesting this was anything but a
positive image and yet I knew that what
they were doing was promoting
an encouragement of this model to
actually continue a pathway to potential
early death because she was morbidly
obese by any clinical analysis so the
fact that you challenge things like that
that you challenge the gender identity
nonsense which leads to biological males
destroying women sport for example all
that kind of stuff the idea that somehow
you're in the wrong and you have to be
re-educated that in a way is a form of
fascism isn't it I mean it's the kind of
Nazism that someone like Trudeau would
profess to hate most in the world and
yet he's encouraging the demonization of
you for challenging the insanity
it's the world of evil clowns man it's
it's Preposterous in the extreme I mean
I you know I'll tell you something else
that's funny about the accusations so
this is this so I'm being pursued by
evil clowns that are incompetent which
is makes it even more comical so you can
go submit a complaint about me by the
way if anyone listening wants to go
submit a complaint about me this is how
you do it you go to the CP Ontario
website and you look up complaints and
you can submit one from anywhere in the
world and you have to fill in this form
that tells uh the people you're
complaining to just why I'm in disgrace
to the profession but the first question
you're asked is that if you were a
client of mine because you know you
think that might be relevant and I think
it's four out of the six complainants
that whose complaints they are pursuing
claimed in writing at the beginning of
their complaints to be clients of mine
which they weren't and not only were
they not clients of mine they didn't
know any clients of mine and they
weren't even they didn't even know any
of the people whose feelings I'd
hypothetically hurt by my tweets and
that was the that was the beginning of
the complaint process and so I pointed
that out to them you know and because I
sent them like 40 questions none of
which they answered and one of them was
well doesn't it strike you as some how
odd that you're taking the word of
someone someone who doesn't even live in
the country often who is never a client
of mine who claimed in writing to be one
and that's the basis of your prosecution
let's say and their answer was well we
don't have to answer any of your stupid
questions and I talk to you that well
we'll see about that let me ask you
about something else sort of they get
tested but the Russell Brand Scandal for
example raises a number of issues you
know I've felt quite strongly for a
while since the metoo time's up
campaigns came along not that I had any
objection to very bad people getting
their comeuppance good I'm glad they
have but the due process was getting
flatlined time after time uh in these
campaigns with with with particular
instances and this strikes me as another
one where Russell Brand has been accused
by a number of women anonymously in most
cases of serious allegations rape and
sexual assault and so on he's vehemently
denied them and yet he's already being
canceled
left right and Center by corporations by
politicians trying to stop tech
companies paying him any money and so on
and so on almost like the the world is
acting as judge jury and executioner
before this guy has had a chance I have
no idea where the truth lies yet with
Russell Brand other than he vehemently
denies these allegations but they are
allegations and they have not yet gone
through due process why are we now doing
this to people where they get
eviscerated destroyed canceled ruined
and convicted in the court of public
opinion before they ever really get a
chance to go through proper legal
process
well part of it is you know we have
people that we're that we admire and
that we aspire to be and and sometimes
For Better or Worse they're often
celebrities and we love them but we kind
of hate them too because they're so
annoying because they're better than us
in many ways and that's why we admire
them and so on the one hand we Elevate
them to a status that we probably
shouldn't Elevate them to but on the
other hand we're pretty damn happy when
we can you know fling them to the ground
and Peck off all their feathers
especially if we can do that at no cost
to ourselves and social media enables
that tremendously because you can
generate a mob of accusers and they can
be anonymous and you can do that in no
time flat and you can Peck the feathers
off someone and you can walk away
feeling real good about yourself and you
can be happy that you got to express
your resentment bitterness and and Away
you go and of course you sacrifice
someone for doing that but it's not you
and and that's just fine and so we're
doing that Non-Stop and and social media
definitely enables that and that's a
huge danger so social media enables
narcissistic psychopathy and that's not
good because we virtualized the world
and we put a tremendous amount of power
in the hands of narcissistic Psychopaths
and I don't say that lightly by the way
there is quite a clinical literature on
trolls online accusatory trolls and
accusatory trolls online tend to be
anonymous and they tend to have dark
Triad personality characteristics and
that's narcissistic Machiavellian
um
uh Psychopathic and because that wasn't
enough it was the dark Triad to begin
with they had to add sadistic which
means takes a positive Delight in the
untoward suffering of others and so
that's the virtual world and that's the
world we live in to a large degree now
and so the accuser has all the power and
that's a real technical problem as well
as a moral problem and that's what's
happened to Russell now Russell you know
I mean Russell's sexual behavior was
exactly the kind of hedonistic nightmare
that all the radicals and progressives
are wrong about non-stop except when it
comes to visit them at home let's say
and and he was celebrated for his
womanizing and and he's apologized for
that and he stopped drinking and he
stopped taking cocaine and it usually
people who engage in licentious and
impulsive behavior of the sort that's
liable to get you in trouble are
extraordinarily Intoxicated by alcohol
at the time of doing it so the mere fact
that he's you know become sober in
recent years and also attempted to tone
for his sins is a real plus I think it
was Nietzsche who said however that just
because you're you think you're done
with your past doesn't mean your past
thinks it's done with you and that's a
dreadful statement and everyone who's
alive should you know be set back on
their Heels by the reality of that but
but hey here we are that's the world we
live in and I'm not so sure that the
cancellation that right I'll ask you on
that way but if it turns out though that
these women are telling the truth and he
is and he is demonstrated to be proven
to be a rapist and sexual assault
presumably you would agree that that is
Despicable and he should be punished for
his crimes
well as you said earlier we have Courts
for determining that and what
constitutes the truth especially in
retrospect particularly in the fog of an
alcoholic encounter let's say is not an
easy thing to to determine and that's
why you have to tret trudge so horribly
through the court system to try to make
sense out of it and of course then what
we do as citizens of a democratic and at
least in principle functional societies
except the verdict of the court but you
don't do that beforehand and you
certainly don't presume that just
because someone's accused it's time to
strip them and throw them out into the
street and the reason you don't do that
in part is if that becomes the norm it
will 100 percent come to visit you and
your loved ones so you know when you
when you when you attribute to someone
else the right to the presumption of
innocence and due process you are
simultaneously absolutely accruing to
yourself that the old that that
privilege and right and we have to
remember that because we're all stupid
we're all fools we all do stupid things
and so we need careful protection for
our own fragility and foolishness and
presumption of innocence and due process
is part of that protective protective
structure we sacrifice that at our great
Peril even though it's so enjoyable to
do so right
did you see the Bobby movie
not yet not yet I plan to see it this
week I want to see it
for what you've gleaned about it read
about it heard about it
it mentions the word patriarchy I think
a dozen times or something oh yeah um
there's no doubt the whole theme of the
thing is that you know you don't really
need men anymore women you can have
everything you want without these
ghastly people and we need to completely
dismantle the whole patriarchy and have
a have a matriarchy right where women
run everything in particularly yeah run
beastly men I mean this this war on the
patriarchy what are your thoughts on
that
well I would say the online World in
many ways is a matriarchy
and the reason I would say that is
because the online World enables female
form anti-social Behavior
and females who are anti-social use
reputation savaging bullying and
exclusion to gain their narcissistic
pathway forward there's a very well
documented psychiatric literature on
female anti-social Behavior and the
online world has many of the elements of
a matriarchy and so there's the
matriarchy for you and I mean I'm not
saying it would be worse or better than
the patriarchy although I you know the
patriarch is a foolish concept to begin
with because it's such a radical
oversimplification but the idea that if
we just replaced a hierarchy of men with
a hierarchy of women or no hierarchy at
all I mean if you think that you're so
foolish that you should be put in
University and educated by people who
know what they're talking about of
course we can't do that at the
universities anymore either so it wasn't
extraordinary on Universities at Harvard
University I think has just been voted
the worst in the world for free speech
almost like it doesn't exist a Harvard
worst in America I think it was I mean
how how can it be the Harvard has become
this barometer of the enemy of free
speech
well it took a lot of work to manage
that it took Decades of of something
approximating foolish conspiratorial uh
maneuvering to manage that I mean you
got to ask yourself is Harvard a
university or a hedge fund I mean has a
massive endowment it seems to me very
often that the university has just a
side show for for the people who govern
the Harvard Harvard's economic Affairs
but but
that aside it's taken a very long time
to let the woke mob and the and the
progressive propagandists take over the
University Systems and Harvard's in the
Forefront and so they managed it a
little earlier and a little better and I
say that by the way with absolutely no
um satisfaction I worked at Harvard in
the 90s I was a professor there from 92
to 97 and I loved it and it was one high
functioning Institute at that time man
it really really valued excellence and
it just didn't talk about that it
actually did it and I love being there
the students were great the professors
were great I really liked my colleagues
it was an admirable place and I still
have colleagues there and they've told
me straight out that it's they don't get
to say what they think the bureaucracy
has taken over the institution the
inmates run the Asylum the professors
are terrified too I've I've had
professors from the Kennedy School tell
me this too that they they can't say
what they think anymore and so when you
let the second Raiders and the
pretenders in and and you let them whine
about victimization and oppression and
you let them usurp the the appropriate
function of the University get exactly
what you deserve and that's exactly what
happened at Harvard and it's still
happening it's not improving I can't
really see how it will I think that to
flip the universities you'd have to do
to them what musk did to Twitter which
is to fire 90 of the people who work
there yeah and that's just not going to
happen so
you know I think the most ridiculous you
started a new University with my
daughters right I'm going to come to
that redress it that way hey when
Michaela joins us I'm gonna we're gonna
talk about that University I I want to
just I mean on the University I I
remember one recent case it was a
professor for 25 years had given a
lecture in the use of offensive language
and as part of the lecture he used
offensive language and he got canceled
for using offensive language and at that
point I realized that parody was dead
right everything was dead I mean in that
moment you couldn't parody the that that
a professor teaching how to use
offensive language using examples of
offensive language then is deemed to
have offended students so much that he
has to get canceled and lose his job I
mean come deeply insane
yeah well welcome to the land ruled by
the evil clown you know that that he has
ascendants so to speak when as you
pointed out you can't parody it it's
gone to the point where it's its own
parody and I see that happening all over
and and part of the way you deal with
that and I mean this most seriously is
you deal without with a with a positive
sense of humor and I can do that when
I'm not ill and I'm feeling much better
even than I did last year when we were
talking and so I can handle it with a
bit of a sense of humor now and you need
to do that if you lose your sense of
humor
in some ways you've been defeated if you
lose yourself I completely agree and if
we don't continue to laugh then these
joyless soulless woke waste rules win
because they are joyless they don't love
anything they are offended by apps no
and they don't like comedians yeah they
find comedy offensive well the moment
people find comedy offensive I find them
so offensive I want nothing to do with
them
you are you can tell the tyrants they
hate two things they hate Comedians and
they hate cars
[Laughter]
that's so true it's so true I want to
talk to you about your new book we who
wrestle with God now a lot of your fans
there's all sorts of Jordan Peterson
groups that you can join who debate
whether you really believe in God or not
so let's just get it on the table do you
believe in God
hahaha I don't think that's any of I
don't think that's anybody's business
I think it's the most private question
you can ask someone but then I would say
also uh what's the right response to
that buy their fruits you will know them
how's that well let me ask you a
difference let me ask you a different
question then do you do you think there
is a God
oh I'm terrified that there might be
Pierce how's that and I you know I'm not
trying to be a smartass when I'm making
that comment either like they say it's
an old it's an Old Testament saying I
believe that the fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom and that's actually
that is actually about his truest
statement as you can manage in such a
short phrase and you know people have
congratulated me I was at the Buckley
Institute last night they were
congratulating me on my courage and I
think and I said this last night it's
like you guys don't understand it has
nothing to do with courage I'm just
afraid of different things than the
people who lie
and I'm afraid for example of what
happens when you lose control of your
tongue and I said that back in 2016 when
I first opposed the Canadian government
and people were you know congratulating
me it's like well you're so brave to
stand up to the government it's like I'm
nowhere near as afraid of the government
as I am of what happens when people lose
control of their tongue I studied
totalitarianism for well since I was 13
years old in depth and I know what
happens when people lose control of
their tongue what happens is everything
goes to hell and I don't mean I mean
that metaphysically I mean it might even
mean it theologically but you can just
say don't even bother with that but
what's fascinating I just mean it
practically but what's interesting is I
completely agree with you by the way um
and you are the most open book of almost
anyone I've ever interviewed right to
the point I asked you if you believe in
God I didn't actually know what you were
going to say but for some reason you're
reluctant to say why are you reluctant
well okay let's let's walk along that
well because it's a it's not a it's not
a well-posed question it's too
complicated an issue to be dealt with
like that you step into instant traps
just by accepting the question so I'll
show you what I mean so the first thing
I would say is what do you mean by
believe
like do you think that a statement about
the existence of God is something like a
scientific theory do you think it's a
list of facts is it a factual question
does God exist or not is it a factual
question like you're asking about
whether a cop on a table exists or a
plate on a table an artifact in a room
what do you mean by this what do you
mean by belief I'll stake my life on the
proposition that God exists how's that
well is that an answer well that's the
right answer I would ask you is my
supplementary do you ever pray
always
who do you pray to
the spirit that protects you from hell
but that many people would say is God
hey
sounds good to me
and so you might say well I said I pray
always so what does that mean
I'm trying to say the most the clearest
words I can say and I do that by paying
attention I'm listening to the words and
feeling them as I move along thinking is
that a firm foundation in the morass is
that a is that a bridge over the abyss
is that word the right word I do that
when I'm writing I do that when I'm
talking
and I do that because I don't want to be
in the abyss
and the pathway over the abyss is the
truth now with regards to belief in God
you might say I know I know that that
you're not particularly religiously
inclined at least that's the theory it's
like well
you have a character Pierce
everyone has a character you could say
that would be the spirit of Pierce
Morgan and then we might say well let's
inquire into that Spirit if you were a
hedonist then the spirit that would be
Pierce Morgan would be your hedonistic
whims
and that would be your God I would say
if you're a noble person then your
spirit is something elevated above your
mere whims and then that's the spirit
that's inculcated within you it's a
consequence perhaps of your
socialization but in a more
sophisticated way it's actually a
consequence of the spirit that you've
allowed as a consequence of your choices
to dwell within you
and that Spirit has a nature it might be
allied with the truth it might be allied
with falsehood if it's allied with the
truth it's a manifestation of what is
being considered traditionally the logos
the more you're aligned with the truth
the more your spirit is an avatar of the
logos that's just it's true it's
religiously true as it turns out but
it's also technically true
it's technically true see I had to do so
I'm going I'm making that case in the
new book right so out of the debate with
Richard Dawkins about this uh he was a
bit disingenuous for me because he sat
with me for a whole show seemed to enjoy
it thank you very much for it and then
called me a fool afterwards in some
podcasts so I I know you've had a few
run-ins with him and it doesn't surprise
me but uh what I said to Dawkins was
because I was raised a Catholic I was
given spiritual guidance for several
years by Catholic nuns and I do believe
in God and the reason I said to him is
that no human brain can really explain
to me or anybody what was there before
before nothing so if you believe in a
Big Bang Theory what was there before
that because I don't think any human
brain has that power to one to explain
or answer that question to me it makes
perfect sense there should be some being
entity something which is superior to a
human brain and I'm I would think that
someone with your brain would think that
too because there are questions okay
okay three things about that so the
first is that's the argument by design
that things are so complex and
sophisticated that that cries out for
the hypothesis of something like a
Creator I'm not a big fan of the
argument by Design I can see its
advantages but it isn't the primary
argument as far as I'm concerned so the
the Big Bang proponents have a problem
because it's a tenet of the big bang
theory that the laws of physics
themselves break down at the point of
the singularity and that would be the
point just before the Big Bang and when
you say the laws of physics the
existence of space and time even is an
unknowable prior to the Big Bang You're
basically positing a miracle at the
beginning of existence and so if you get
to have your miracle there's no reason
the religious types can't have theirs
you might argue about what the miracle
needs to be and I think that's an
argument that has to be had I don't like
the argument by Design I like the
argument by conscience better
so the argument by conscience which is
another string of classic theological
thought is that something dwells within
you that aligns you with the spirit of
reality and it's the still Small Voice
Within that was identified first by the
Prophet Elijah and it was part of a
transformation in the religious
Viewpoint in historical terms that moved
the notion of God from something like
Bal
b-a-l-b-e-b-a-a-l a nature God the god
of Storms and earthquakes of of of what
would you say remarkable and
awe-inspiring natural phenomena to the
voice within that can if you attend to
it align you with the structure of
reality itself that internal voice being
a manifestation of God and I think
that's an extremely powerful argument
and I think it's right and I'll tell you
something about Dawkins work that's very
interesting so Dawkins has pointed out
that an organism has to be a microcosm
of its environment in order to survive
and I would say the con the voice of
conscience within us is the most
unerring manifestation of the microcosm
within and I think you can make it
extraordinarily powerful biological case
for that and I've done that in this new
book
so I think Dawkins argument I think
Dawkins argument invalidates his
his epistemology yeah I agree I really
believe that but what do you think I
mean you've had moments in your life in
recent years well I would imagine you
have faced the prospect of potentially
dying
and in those moments in those moments
what have you felt and what do you think
happens to you if you do die
or you had died what what did you
imagine might happen to you
well I had lots of moments moments years
in the last few years where dying would
have been an absolute relief and had
that been accompanied by the complete
cessation of my being I would have been
perfectly content with that there are
things that are far worse than dying so
if you're only terrified of dying you've
hardly begun to plumb the depths of
existential catastrophe death you just
don't have an imagination well it could
be worse than dying
being a prison guard at Auschwitz
would you still be alive even if you're
witnessing horror it's not death
I am thinking perpetrating it
right
you mean how about how about being an
Auschwitz guarded how about being an
Auschwitz guard who really enjoyed his
job
how about that that's worse than death
as far as I'm concerned right I mean
that no no I see that that's hell man
yeah it's a living hell that's hell yeah
I agree
but do you think so but do you think
there's an actual hell Jordan is it is
there somewhere that people like that go
to which is hell
oh definitely now what what relationship
that has to what happens to you when you
die I have no idea I mean I don't think
anybody is in a position to speak about
what's truly beyond our Ken let's say I
don't think we understand Consciousness
at all we don't understand time we don't
understand the relationship between
finitude and in and and and and the
infinite landscape that surrounds us
that's all a great mystery and I tend to
leave that alone because I try not to
speak about things that I can't speak
about but does Hell exist it's like
study history and see if you can figure
it out for yourself does heaven is
nothing there's nothing that's more
obvious than that hell exists it does
heaven exist Mao's China was hell right
but does so you're talking about hell on
Earth but do you believe there's a hell
after death
like I said I I I can't I can't I don't
speculate about such things I don't
that's where my ignorance Finds Its
what would you say that's where my
knowledge Finds Its limit I'm I'm
concerned enough about what I'm doing
right now right here and and leaving the
rest of that and you know I'm
so I have to leave it at that the hell
that I see as a potential on Earth is
sufficient as a deterrent
and it's of sufficient reality you know
you can ask well is it Eternal well then
I would say well look all totalitarian
states are variants on a theme let's say
and that theme
persists all archetypal stories are
Eternal everything that happened in the
Bible happened and is happening and will
continue to happen forever it's part of
the Eternal human story it's hyper real
and Heaven and Hell are part of that
what that means in the final analysis I
don't know I mean you asked I think you
asked in there you know their hell is
real is heaven real it's like well
Heaven is as far away from hell as you
can get that's a good way of thinking
about it
um I've spent my whole life trying to
determine how you get as far away from
being a camp guard at Auschwitz who
enjoys his job as possible and one of
the things one of the things I've
realized in recent years for example is
that you are far from that if you're
engaging in
your interactions with the world in the
spirit of voluntary play
you know when we're playing during this
conversation and Joe Rogan plays on his
podcast all the time and if you're in a
playful state with your wife your
marriage is optimized and the state of
play is the opposite of tyranny and
that's why it says in the gospels that
if you want to enter the Kingdom of
Heaven you have to become like a little
child
so
you want to reinstate that that
open-eyed wide-eyed acceptance of life
that is the precursor to voluntary play
you want to develop your character to
the point where that's part and parcel
of your life on an ongoing basis and
that's allowing that Spirit of the logos
to inhabit you that's another way of
thinking about it and you can you can
certainly Aid that with prayer
you know people don't understand people
think of God as the joke is a cosmic
Butler you pray to have your wishes
granted it's like
he's not a genie
you want to you want to pray he's like
pray about your stupidity here's a
prayer that'll work for sure you want to
see if prayer Works here's one this will
work sit on the edge of your bed
ask yourself
what bloody stupid thing do I continue
to do that's making my life more
miserable than it has to be and everyone
else's life around me that I could give
up that I would give up
and you bet you have to really want the
answer so you open yourself up in
humility to a revelation you'll get an
answer
it won't be when you want that's how
you'll know it's true but if you act on
it then your life will improve and
that's a proper prayer yeah that's
that's what you do like in a
metaphysical sense the Christian
insistence that you should be aware of
your sins you know which is incense in a
sense an existential burden is also the
idea that you should attend to your own
inadequacies and admit to them because
in doing so you open up the possibility
that something better can make itself
manifest within you and there's no doubt
that that's the case that's for sure
that's true but you have to do it in
humility and you have to be looking
that's why you're supposed to take the
moat out of your own eye instead of
worrying about the beam in your
neighbor's eye it's like there's
something about you that's stupid you
can fix and God will tell you what it is
if you want them to so to speak
I want to end this part of the uh the
interview just with you John before we
bring your daughter in um my team were
curious whether you would be able
actually physically able to answer
questions which is one word answers
because you think about things on such a
high intellectual plane you're very
articulate you're very thoughtful about
it so I just want to throw a few
questions and just see whether you can
I'm not saying you have to I'm just
saying can you something straightforward
some a little bit more complex but
what's one piece of music we should all
listen to
Hank Williams
which which song
any of them
which song Lovesick Blues
well the supplementary is why
plaintive truth
perfect can money make you happy
yes
I'm not alone
what did you say that
not not by itself right
but having money would make you more
happy than not having money
having money and opportunity are very
similar and why is having
how it can be better
how many hours of sleep is Optimum for
the human mind to work properly
it seems that the the
about eight by the looks of things
is marriage good for you
compared to the alternative
is owning a pet a good idea
definitely not pugs though dogs or cats
because I I find that that's hugs
anything but a pug I've had two I love
pugs I've had two cats for two cats for
about 10 months my first pets since I
was a teenager and I find them to be
utter charlatans like whoever gives the
most affection gets gets them whereas my
family who have dogs they're very
affectionate to everybody that they're
not disloyal at the cats
I I like dogs and cats but I prefer cats
because they bite you now and then when
you don't expect it and I think that's I
think that's hilarious they're kind of
like women that way
how am I talking to you women how much
sex
is Optimum
per week per month well my experience as
a clinician I'll give you a slightly
longer answer to this
um my experience as a clinician is that
people who are married need to
communicate about the the daily their
daily issues for about 90 minutes a week
and they need to spend at least two they
need to have two dates a week minimum to
sustain their relationship across time
now you know it varies with the couple
obviously but that's 90 minutes of
business-like communication to set the
to set everything straight and to keep
you updated with your partner and then
you have to spend you have to have two
dates a week to keep the romance in your
life alive and it's really really really
important to do that and you can do that
but you have to work at it and by date
so you including sex so twice a week is
Optimum depends on how the date goes man
you should know that
should people go to therapy or can it
really screw you up
depends on the therapist and why they go
it can be very very helpful there's no
real difference between a therapeutic
relationship and a genuine relationship
and so the question really is are
genuine relationships beneficial to
people and the answer to that is of
course and you might say well can you
mimic a genuine relationship in a
therapy practice and the answer is yes
it's not as good as a marriage if it's a
good marriage it's maybe not even as
good as a great friendship but if you
lack both of those then a Therapeutic
Alliance can be extraordinarily helpful
now if your therapist is in cautious and
poorly trained and foolish and
ideologically adult
then it can be a complete bloody
nightmare but everything's like that
right if you go to a surgeon who doesn't
know what he's doing well yeah you know
he'll cut off the wrong leg and that's
often not a good thing
who is the one philosopher we should all
read
oh I don't know if any if there's any
philosopher we should we should all read
Nietzsche
breakfast lunch is deadly well breakfast
lunch or dinner what's the most
important meal of the day
breakfast
and Abra mccraven have you ever saw this
speech gave a fantastic speech with one
of top military guys in the American
Military and it was basically centered
around making your bed that the very
first thing you should do each day is
make your bed because instead of
discipline for your day and a purpose
and got you going
what would your yeah what would your
advice be for the first thing people
should do when they get up
open their eyes
and look around them
it's a good thing to do all day is open
your damn eyes
and we'll see what's right in front of
you well the bad the bed making bed
making duplicates the cosmic order by
the way right because you make order out
of chaos and that's a good thing to do
when you first awaken because you're
reenacting the the creation of the world
in a symbolic manner
and finally on this part of this it's a
good way to get your day going yeah it
is the final part of this uh section
what is the best and worst thing about
being Jordan Peterson
the worst
I'm a bit much
and the best you might say so what's the
best thing I'm sort of running in I'm
running in all directions very rapidly
and so
that can be
a bit much it's hard on people around me
I'm a bit much man
and what's the best thing about you
the best thing about being me yeah
it's overwhelming really well the Deep
appreciation that people have for what
I've been doing
it's stunning it's it's Soul destroying
but it's amazing is it not Soul
enhancing I mean I feel it when I do
interviews with you the reaction I get
from people just how much you mean to
them I mean I can imagine it yeah well
that's a bit much you know I mean look
when I go wherever I go it's so strange
because wherever I go it's like I have
friends there because I walk down the
street and people wave at me and you
know they call up my name and
a bit much it's amazing it's really
something but it's amazing but it's hard
to
it's it is it's hard to it's hard to
wrap my head around it it's very hard to
wrap my head around it and especially
because it happened to me you know when
I was well I didn't when I was older
than 50. it's been quite an adjustment I
wouldn't say it's what I've made
and it's an amazing it's an immense
responsibility and I'm not complaining
about that at all I'd be a fool to
complain an ungrateful fool but
it's um
you know it's a strange thing to have
far more than you could
ever imagine
what do you mean
well that's my life I have far more than
I could ever imagine
I didn't think it was possible
I mean you've become somebody who in the
later stage of a life now you did it
again you guard me again god well this
yeah it's it's very interesting I mean
you are you are an emotional person I
know that
um but I think it's also interesting to
me what makes you emotional and it in a
way it's similar to why you were
emotional last time I talked to you is
that you are very acutely aware of the
influence you now have over so many
millions of people
and I think you feel that responsibility
profoundly and I think that's what
triggers it grab you an emotion
yeah it's gratitude yeah
no imagine someone gave you everything
you could possibly imagine
and more well that's the situation I'm
in
and do you find it do you find it
overwhelming sometimes
always
yeah
I think that's partly what made me ill
it's an amazing thing Jordan I want to I
can't think of a better segue actually
than to bring in for the next part of
this interview your daughter Michaela
who will have been I'm sure watching
this and knows you better than anybody
so we're going to come back and have the
second part which is two Petersons for
the price of one
terrible thing to inflict on the world
laughs